قالت ليندا توماس جرينفيلد مندوبه
الولايات المتحده في مجلس الامن ان وقف
التمويل الامريكي لوكاله الاونروا هو وقف
مؤقت واكدت اهميه الوكاله لتقديم المساعده
المنقذه للحياه في غزه وعبرت عن ترحيبها
بتحقيق الامم المتحده في المزاعم بشان
مشاركه موظفين في الوكاله في هجمات السابع
من
اكتوبر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قالق
حيال المزعم بانه هناك 12 موظفا ربما
شاركوا في الهجمات في السابع من اكتوبر
وكما تعلمون
الوزاره اعلنت عن وقفه مؤقته في حين اننا
نراجع هذه المزاعم والامم المتحده تتخذ
خطوات للتطرق لهذه المساله نحن نرحب بقرار
الامم المتحده بالقيام بتحقيق شامل وتقييم
مستقل لاعمال الاونر و الامين العام تعهد
بسرعه بانه سوف يتخذ اجراءات حاسمه للرد
اذا كانت هذه المزاعم حقيقيه ويجب ان يكون
هناك مسائله لاي شخص يشارك في او شارك في
هذه الهجمات في السابع من اكتوبر ولكننا
نعلم ايضا ان الاونر تؤدي دورا مهما في
تامين المساعده المنقذه للارواح
للفلسطينيين بما في ذلك الاغذيه والادويه
والماوى وغيرها من
الانسانيه المه
للحياه ودعى المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه ماثيو ميلر الام المتحده
للتحقيق في الادعاءات ضد وكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الاونر واضاف ميلر
في مؤتمر صحفي ان عمل الوكاله في غزه لا
يمكن الاستغناء عنه ويجب ان
يستمر ينضم الينا من بيروت علي هويدي
المدير العام للهيئه للدفاع عن حقوق
الهيئه 302 للدفاع عن حقوق اللاجئين
والخبير في شؤون الونر يعني استاذ علي
اهلا
بك اليست هنالك اي وجاهه في قرارات الدول
التي قررت مقاطعه او وقف التمويل
لونر بسبب هذه المزاعم الاسرائيليه يعني
ان تكون منظمه و يوجه فيها الاتهام في
تحقيق تجريه المنظمه ذاتها
ب لموظفين بانهم شاركوا في هجوم كل العالم
الذي يؤيد الاونر ويمولها يراه هجوما
ارهابيا الا ترى وجاهه في قرارات هذه
الدول يعني انا اعتقد بان اقدام الاداره
الامريكيه يعني على اتخاذ هذا القرار وهي
يعني اولى الدول التي اتخذت هذه القرارات
ثم انضم اليها 14 دوله اخرى ليصل العدد
الى 15 دوله يعني هذا القرار اقل ما يقال
عنه بانه قرار ظالم وهذا طبعا يتناقض مع
القيم والمعايير الانسانيه التي تتحدث
عنها تلك الدول لا يعقل ابدا بان يتم
معاقبه اكثر من 6 مليون لاجئ فلسطيني مسجل
في سجلات وكاله الانور في مناطق عملياتها
الخمسه بسبب ان هناك مزاع او اتهامات
تتعلق بعدد قليل من
الموظفين ربما شاركوا في في عمليه 7
اكتوبر وبالمناسبه حتى هذه اللحظه ايضا لم
يتم البدء بعمليه التحقيق من من قبل
مكتب مكتب خدمات الرقابه العامه في الامم
المتحده في نيويورك فكيف يتم اتخاذ قرارات
قبل ان يتم
التصل بنتائج يعني الانرو فصلت هذا طبعا
وهذه
مفارقه وهذا وهذه طبعا يعني هذا خطا كبير
جدا بان يتم ايضا يعني فصل هؤلاء الموظفين
من قبل وكاله الانر بناء على لقاء حصل ما
بين المفوض العام لوكاله الانر فيليب
لازاريني وسلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وعندما تم تقديم اسماء 12 موظف فولا فورا
بادر المفوض العام وفصل هؤلاء الموظفين
وهذه تعتبر بالفعل سابقه بان يتم اتخاذ
اجراءات عقابيه او اجراءات صارمه بفصل
هؤلاء الموظفين الموظفين دون ان يتم يعني
التثبت من الاتهامات وال والمزاعم خاصه
بانها هذه لا تزال تحت مسمى مزاعم واذا
عدنا ايضا
الى عن ثمانيه ما تاثير ذلك على الا لو
عدنا نعم لو عدنا حتى الى يعني ما الذي
قام به هؤلاء الثمانيه موظفين وال والذين
تم نشر اسمائهم بانهم فقط يعني كانت لهم
تعليقات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي منهم
من اشاد بالعمليه ومنهم من وضع صوره ابو
عبيده على حسابه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي حتى احنا حتى ان احدى المعلمات
العامله في وكاله الاونر في قطاع غزه
استشهد جميع افراد عائلتها فوضعت فقط يعني
تعبير عن دعم للمقاومه والصلاه للمقاومه ب
ان بان تنتصر لا يعقل ان ان يكون هذه يعني
ال
المشاركات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ان
يؤخذ بحق هؤلاء الموظفين الاجراءات على
مستوى الفصل ولا يعقل ايضا بان تقوم هذه
الدول بتعليق مساهماتها الماليه لوكاله
الاونه خاصه اذا اخذنا بع الاعتبار بانه
بقطع هذه المساهمات هذا يعني بانها ستقفل
ما يقارب من 715 مدرسه تديرها الاونر في
مناطق عمليه الخمسه ما بين ابتدائي وما
بين متوسط و ما بين ثانوي ايضا سيتم اغلاق
ما يقارب من 140 مركز صحي في في المخيمات
التي تعمل فيها وكال شكرا جزيلا يعني الا
مرت بازمات
كثيره وكانت هنالك محاولات من جانب الدول
العربيه لسد هذه الفجوات التمويليه في بعض
الاحيان خصوصا حينما اوقفت الولايات
المتحده من قبل تمويلها لا ندري ان كان
ذلك سيحدث في المستقبل ام لا لكن نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا من غزه من بيروت عفوا عليه واد
المدير العام للهيئه 302 للدفاع عن حقوق
اللاجئين والخبير في شؤون الانرو